ENEMY IST IN THE TIRTIE ABOVE!
Ich habe mir heute was gekauft, was wir morgen und am Wochenende einrichten müssen.
Das werde ich vielleicht auch in einem YouTube Video verwursten, da könnt ihr dann Hallo YouTube oder irgendwas spammen.
Also nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt, morgen, wenn wir uns das angucken.
Jetzt könnt ihr jetzt auch spammen, aber das hat jetzt noch keinen Sinn.
Und zwar wisst ihr, was ich mir gekauft habe, ich habe mir ein Kommerkiste.
Als erstes, ich habe mir sogar zwei Sachen, ich habe mir zwei Sachen geholt.
Was sagst du zum Microsoft-Ausfall? Ich habe jetzt gar nicht mehr dran nachgeguckt, was jetzt genau gewesen ist.
Also ich habe es mitgekriegt. Teams ging nicht richtig, Azure Services ging teilweise nicht richtig.
Also auch Sachen, die man dort gehostet hat, ging teilweise nicht richtig.
Office, Outlook und so ging nicht richtig. Ich weiß nicht, woran es gelegen hat.
Vielleicht irgendwelche Netzwerk-Rooting-Geschichten oder so mal wieder.
Also ich habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt, woran es letztendlich lag.
Aber Microsoft hat geschrieben, wir may experience irgendwelche Ausfälle.
Und ja, die habe ich, die habe ich experienced.
Ja, also wollte ich euch ja erzählen, was ich, was ich geholt habe.
Zwei Sachen, zwei Sachen habe ich geholt. Das eine ist eher allgemein gut für einen Stream.
Und das zweite ist für Wochenende Poggers Bastel-Stells.
Und zwar, ich habe mir ein paar Sachen geholt, die ich mir in die Hand gebracht habe.
Das eine ist eher allgemein gut für einen Stream. Und das zweite ist für Wochenende Poggers Bastel-Stells.
Und zwar, das erste, was ich mir geholt habe, ist endlich mal eine gescheite Capture-Karte wieder.
Nämlich eine HD60X von Elgato. Ich habe ja noch zwei Elgatos hier, also aus den Zeiten,
als wir noch Call of Duty-Sponsoring und sowas gemacht haben.
Aber die haben halt immer richtig eklig lag damals gehabt.
Da musste alles über USB 2 gehen und da mussten es encode und das hat halt irgendwie so 2-3 Sekunden teilweise gedauert.
Das konnte man gar nicht richtig benutzen, alles hier im Stream. Das war Müll.
Mr. Moo Game, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Also ich habe mir eine gescheite Capture-Karte gekauft.
Da können wir jetzt alles Mögliche auch mal anstöpseln und ohne Verzögerung benutzen.
Aber viel besser, was ich mir bestellt habe fürs Wochenende.
Am Wochenende bauen wir nämlich Linux-Emulator. Also nein, wir bauen kein Emulator, das Linux emulieren kann.
Wir bauen eine Konsolen-Emulator-Kiste.
Und zwar, ich habe mir was bestellt. Das Video letztens hat mich inspiriert.
Und zwar, ich habe mir natürlich mal wieder was Gescheites bestellt.
Und zwar einen... Wobei, bringt ja nichts, wenn ich euch das sage. Ich zeige es euch einfach mal.
Und zwar habe ich mir bestellt ein... Wir müssen mal kurz hier aufmachen.
Ein Miniforms UM690. So ein Teil habe ich mir bestellt.
Das ist das Falsche, was hier ausgewählt wurde. So einen habe ich mir bestellt.
Ein UM690, 32G RAM, 512GB Festplatte.
Und da kommt dann Linux drauf mit allen möglichen Emulatoren.
Selbstverständlich im Stream natürlich nur original selbst gerippte Xbox, Wii und Gamecube Spiele.
Versteht sich ja von selbst.
So, und das Ding ist mega nice. Ich habe mir den Test angeguckt.
Wir können uns theoretisch auch ein Video angucken.
Retro Gaming. Das da.
Das habe ich mir vorher angeguckt. Und da kam das richtig gut bei weg.
Also es sind drinne. Kann ich mal vorlesen, was da hinten drauf steht.
Das ist ein Miniforms UM690. Mini PC, 32GB RAM, 512GB SSD, M2 SSD.
Ein AMD Ryzen 9 6900HX. Das ist mit integrierter Grafikkarte und die ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Damit kann man sogar PC-Games, halbwegs neue PC-Games in ganz guter Qualität spielen.
Was ich auf dem Fernsehen nicht machen will, aber es ist halt schön klein und kompakt.
Es hat ungefähr die Größe von einem Xbox-Controller das Ding. Sieht jetzt hier so groß aus, ist es nicht.
Über die Größe vom Xbox, also Breite von dem Xbox-Controller und oben und unten steht es ein bisschen ab.
Und da installieren wir dann Linux drauf.
Und probieren mal Emulator-Stells aus am Wochenende. Mal gucken, ob das taugt.
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt. Ja ja, Mitte Januar. Also ich habe es mir bei Amazon bestellt.
Amazon hat wieder richtig gebaitet. Wenn man nämlich bei Amazon danach sucht, findet man nichts richtig.
Das guckt euch mal an. Da findet man dann Dinger für 999 Euro.
Was gebait ist, was richtig krasser gebait ist, weil...
Hier. Ich weiß nicht, warum die so dämlich gemacht haben.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die so dämlich gemacht haben. Also anstatt, dass sie das einfach 150 Euro billiger gemacht hätten,
gibt es einen 150 Euro Gutschein. Total weird champ.
Das sieht halt keiner. Jeder denkt sich, fuck ist das teuer, das kaufe ich nicht.
Aber es kostet halt im Prinzip das gleiche wie im Shop und ist noch lieferbar.
Du hast deinen HM90. Ja, die Dinger sollen wirklich ganz gut. Der HM90 habe ich auch überlegt, weil der eine dedizierte Grafikkarte hat.
Aber es nimmt sich im Endeffekt für die Plattformen, die ich emulieren will, gar nicht so viel. Und der ist größer.
Also was ich darauf machen will, ist eindeutig Super Nintendo N64.
Vielleicht ein bisschen PS1 und PS2. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht so, was mich da interessiert.
Ich meine, PS1 und PS2 dürften den größten Spielekanalog auf der Welt haben, also den es jemals gegeben hat.
Ich glaube, PS2 ist bis heute noch die meistverkaufte Konsole. Vor allem will ich Wii emulieren.
Und theoretisch kann man auch Switch darauf emulieren. Das soll angeblich auch ganz gut laufen.
Und Gamecube. Also hauptsächlich, ehrlich gesagt, älteres Nintendo Zeug, weil ich unter anderem so doof war.
Ich habe ja mein N64 und meine Wii damals weggeschmissen beim Umzug. Außer die Games, die habe ich noch.
Ohne Witz, die Games habe ich wirklich noch. Games, genauso wie ich die ganzen Xbox Games noch habe.
Aber ganz einfach und abgesehen will ich die ganzen Konsolen eigentlich gar nicht ins Wohnzimmer stellen.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt. Guck, und die Plattform ist wirklich nice. Wir gehen hier mal ein bisschen vor.
Also man kann, man kann hier rauf sogar, guckt euch das mal an.
Man kann hier drauf sogar mit Upscaling, mit Upscaling kann man 3DS und Wii Spiele laufen lassen.
Und sogar Wii U Games. Gut, Breath of the Wild will ich da drauf nicht spielen, aber...
Man, das läuft alles relativ, relativ gut. Das ist Upscaled auf 180p.
Wie gesagt, Wii U Spiele bin ich eh nicht so scharf drauf. Eine Wii U habe ich sogar noch irgendwo.
Bei mir wird es wahrscheinlich bei Wii Spielen auf. Aber ist schon nice.
Das Ding läuft garantiert flüssiger als auf der Switch. Okay, das neue Pokémon weiß ich nicht,
aber ältere Pokémon sehen besser aus wahrscheinlich als das neue und laufen dort flüssiger,
weil Nintendo sich überhaupt keine Mühe mehr gibt für die Games.
Jetzt wird meine VM starten. Dort basteln wir nämlich weiter.
Pog.
Guck mal, wie schnell das jetzt mit M2 SSD geht. Flutscht richtig. Gatchibuzz.
Ja, da werden wir uns am Wochenende ein bisschen dran... Warte, ich muss mal ein bisschen zumachen jetzt.
Wie viel? Da werden wir uns am Wochenende... Ja, genau. Exakt.
Ach, das Heute-Command ist gar nicht mehr drin. Das Heute-Command vom letzten Mal hätte gut gepasst,
dass wir an unserer Linux Kiste weiter basteln und sie weiter hübsch machen.
Kannst du einen Valdetudo Staubsauger empfehlen? Nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich habe einen Roborock S5, den ich nicht mehr verwende.
Wenn überhaupt, würde ich mir einen holen mit Absaugstation.
Aber die neuen Roborock-Dinger funktionieren zwar noch oder wieder.
Wieder muss man sagen, die neuen Roborock-Dinger funktionieren wieder.
Allerdings musst du die aufmachen und an die Kontakte zum Flaschen. Das ist doof.
Moin, Patrick. Also, das ist doof.
Was du kaufen kannst, sind diese Dreamy-Dinger, glaube ich.
Aber da habe ich keine Erfahrung mit.
Nightbot nicht im Chat, Nightbot Brocken.
Ja, da basteln wir heute auch noch ein bisschen dran rum.
Mal gucken.
Kannst du mir einen Lilux-Destroyer empfehlen?
Ich würde sagen...
Ja, aber dir bleibt eigentlich nur noch Gentoo übrig, oder?
Der Rest ist doch zu Easy Mode.
Da muss erst mal zwei Stunden kompiliert werden und um den E-Mail...
Ich kann nicht mehr reden, Alter.
Da muss erst mal zwei Stunden kompiliert werden, um den E-Mail-Anhang zu öffnen.
Ich hatte mal einen Kollege auf der Arbeit, der hatte Gentoo.
Und der hat das Ding irgendwie am Anfang dreimal neu kompiliert,
den Colonel bis die VM seine Netzwerkkarte unterstützt hat,
dass er Zeug nachladen kann.
Also, man kann es irgendwie auch übertreiben.
Arch Linux.
Ja, das wissen wir alle.
Das ist eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr erwähnenswert.
Das ist Default, by the way, Arch.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe Gentoo auch noch nie richtig verwendet.
Ich habe auch überhaupt keinen Bock, mich mit Gentoo zu beschäftigen,
weil ich sehe den Vorteil von mir überhaupt nicht drin.
Warum sollte ich das selbst kompilieren?
Ich meine, bei Arch kannst du aus User Repos auch relativ viel kompilieren,
aber warum, also verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, das funktioniert aber nicht.
Battleship, das funktioniert nicht.
Glaub mir, ich habe mir alle schon angeguckt.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Weißt du, warum es nicht funktioniert?
Weil es keine Mobile Notifications unterstützt.
An sich wäre das...
Alter, bei Augen ist es viel zu hell.
Das kann keine Mobile Notifications.
Das kann man ja getrennt ausprobieren, den Package Manager und das OS.
Ja, habe ich.
Nee, nicht mal Bluetooth-Dongle.
Mit meinem Onboard-Bluetooth habe ich die Dinger geflasht.
Nicht vom Raspberry Pi aus, sondern vom Desktop-PC aus.
Ging besser.
Die Musik eskaliert wieder voll.
Woop, woop, woop, woop.
Du willst Mobile-Anwendungen entwickeln?
Dann, goodluck, have fun.
Also ich würde ja, wenn ich Mobile-Anwendungen basteln müsste,
würde ich wahrscheinlich irgendwie was Richtung Ionic machen.
Aber nur vom Hören sagen, ich habe damit noch nichts gemacht.
Das alles, was ich bisher gesehen habe, hat mich davon am meisten angesprochen.
Ja, ich weiß, der Rest ist wirklich nice.
Ich würde es auch verwenden.
Ich will aber Mobile Notifications für To-Do's und sowas haben.
Jetzt vergesse ich noch was.
Wenn ich denn mal Notifications habe, dann...
So, wir machen mal kurz ein Update.
Was?
Wer nicht installiert?
Es...
Eine Runde updaten.
Wenn ich jetzt noch richtig tippen könnte,
das wäre natürlich richtig...
Richtig poggers.
Einmal updaten und dann geht es weiter.
Wir basteln heute noch ein bisschen weiter an unserer neuen Linux-VM.
Beziehungsweise an unserem Arch-By-The-Way-Linux.
Woop, woop, woop, woop, woop, woop, woop, woop, woop.
Die Musik eskaliert mir zu sehr.
Auch wenn es sehr catchy Soundtrack ist.
Den lasse ich übrigens, während ich arbeite,
sehr gerne nebenbei laufen.
Das ist ein absolut poggers Soundtrack.
Jetzt wird es mir zu anstrengend.
Und mal so.
Okay.
Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich finde es auch...
Ich würde prinzipiell Obsidian verwenden.
Nicht nur, weil es eine saumäßig große Community mittlerweile hat.
Mir fehlt einfach Task-Management und Mobile-Notifications.
Da gibt es ja schon lange bei denen einen PR.
Äh, kein PR.
So ein Feature Request.
Wenn die das einbauen, dann...
Aber das ist schon seit zwei Jahren offen.
Dann wäre ich dabei.
Was mich da auch ein bisschen stört, ist,
dass es eben nicht Open Source ist.
Wobei ich sagen muss, wenn die was abziehen würden,
das hätte man wahrscheinlich schon gemerkt.
Das ist jetzt kein Ausschlusskriterium an der Stelle.
Ich bin ja nicht hier Richard Stallman.
Wenn das nicht Open Source ist, dann...
Jetzt mal eine blöde Frage.
Wie können die Pull-Requests haben?
Wie können die Pull-Requests haben,
ohne dass es den Source-Code dafür gibt?
Oder sind das die Plugins?
Ach nee, das ist die Plugin.
Das ist die Plugin-Liste. Ach so.
Ja, okay, okay. Na dann.
Okay, das ergibt natürlich Sinn.
Wir hatten einmal Android Studio installiert im Stream.
Mit dem Emulator ging das eigentlich easy.
Aber ich habe ja kein Gerät dazu connectet.
Nix zum Updaten, okay.
Wir rebooten mal kurz.
Okay, das sind jetzt zwei Versionen.
Aber normalerweise sind Debian Upgrades relativ easy zumindest.
Es sei denn, die Version ist neu und an der Konfig hat sich was geändert,
dass du deine Konfig anpassen musst.
Will man dann eher nicht on the fly live machen.
So, als erstes muss ich jetzt mal was umstellen,
was mich extrem triggert jedes Mal, wenn ich es sehe.
Und zwar, ich muss die Notification Bar eins größer machen,
damit ich keine Lücken mehr zwischen den Blöcken habe.
Sonst drehe ich durch.
Nginx hat es zerrissen.
Ja, das kommt natürlich vor.
Wir brauchen auch einen ordentlichen Font für unseren Launcher.
Toll, ich bin immer noch ein bisschen hin und hergerissen.
Und zwar, was ich für einen Launcher verwenden soll.
Ich hatte mir jetzt mal Offstream Yu Launcher angeguckt.
Yu Launcher ist von der Idee her eigentlich ganz cool.
Also da kann man, ich stelle mal kurz um.
Elementary Dark will ich haben.
Yu Launcher ist von der Idee her eigentlich ganz cool, aber
es gibt ein paar Sachen, die mich nervt.
Also wofür das da ist, ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen.
Da kann man jetzt zum Beispiel Anwendungen drüber starten.
Drückt man einfach einen Shortcut und sagt dann Firefox.
Es ist im Prinzip eine schönere Variante von Yu Menu,
nur dass es halt mit Plugins erweiterbar ist.
An sich ist das eigentlich eine ganz coole Geschichte.
Auch dass du direkt Google Search aufmachen kannst,
ist eigentlich ganz nice das Ding.
Aber so ein paar Sachen nerven mich.
Zum Beispiel, dass es manchmal einfach zugeht.
Das habe ich auch schon.
Wenn ich rausgehe, obwohl ich manchmal drinnen bin,
denkt er, ich bin draußen.
Also es gibt Plugins.
Das ist schon mal an sich eine coole Geschichte.
Zum Beispiel gibt es den Yu Launcher Clipboard Plugin.
Ich mag ja Software, die du mit Plugins erweitern kannst.
Da kann man nämlich selbst sich daran austoben.
Nehmen wir das jetzt mal.
Jetzt kann man das starten.
Ich kopiere mal kurz ein paar Sachen, dass ihr es seht.
Dann öffnet man das und dann sagt man C.
Dann hat man hier eben seine Clipboard History.
Manchmal, und das ist auch, wie gesagt,
ich habe das Offstream schon ein bisschen.
Ihr habt es gesehen?
Jetzt hat er es wieder nicht gefressen.
Gucken wir mal, ob er es jetzt hat.
Ne.
Jetzt hat er wieder keinen Bock mehr.
Also manchmal funktioniert das einfach nicht.
Manchmal funktioniert es einfach nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist es wieder zuge...
Wahrscheinlich ist die Extension jetzt gecrashed oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Also irgendwie habe ich ein Problem,
dass manchmal der in diesem...
Nochmal MaxLine2 schon, okay.
Dass der manchmal die Clipboard Änderungen nicht mitbekommt.
Das ist schon ein bisschen doof.
Jetzt habe ich dem Menu und dem Menu gelauncht.
Das ist natürlich auch sehr schlau.
Funktioniert aus irgendwelchen Gründen wieder nicht.
Weiß nicht.
Ist wahrscheinlich wieder ab.
Irgendwas mit Clipboard abgekackt.
So, aber ich habe...
ULauncher werde ich an sich irgendwie nicht so 100% warm mit.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es cool, dass man das erweitern kann.
Aber mir gefällt beispielsweise der Clip,
das Clipboard Manager Plugin nicht.
Erstens ist es extrem lahm.
Ich habe mal Just For Fun ein paar Sachen da reinkopiert.
Also wenn man z.B. sagt, yes.
Head minus N...
Also wir machen jetzt einfach mal 9999 Zeilen,
wo J drinne steht.
Oder nicht J, Y.
Passt so schlimm wie W drinne steht.
Und wenn man das jetzt mal X-Clip...
Da X-Clip ist noch immer drauf.
Haben wir denn die anderen Sachen wenigstens drauf?
Ja.
So, X-Clip.
Was ist mal so mit...
Minus Minus Selection.
Yes, X-Clip.
Und jetzt haben wir das Ganze in der Zwischenablage.
Und wenn ich das Ding jetzt dazu überreden könnte,
mal zu funktionieren,
dann würdet ihr sehen, dass es mega langsam wird,
wenn man größere und längere Einträge im Clipboard hat.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich starte den Krempel einfach nochmal neu.
Hi Max, ich habe eine Frage.
Ich bin Business Consultant, BC.
Gut, wichtig, dass man das abkürzen kann.
Und etwas unzufrieden mit meiner Bezahlung momentan.
Jetzt bietet mein Unternehmen,
allen BCs an Schulungen zu machen,
an denen mein Interesse hat, die Schulungen kosten 30 bis...
Du meinst jetzt wahrscheinlich, du meinst 4K,
nicht 4.000K, weil 4.000K ist ein bisschen viel.
Das würde ich auf jeden Fall nehmen.
3.000 bis 4.000 Euro inklusive Zeit.
Die Schulungen würde ich gerne mitnehmen.
Ich habe aber Schiss, dass die mir ein schlechtes Arbeitszeug geben,
falls ich eins bis zwei Monate...
Das dürfen die gar nicht.
Immer unabhängig davon, dass sie es vielleicht versuchen können.
Ich bin kein Unternehmen,
nicht das an irgendwelche Bedingungen knüpft.
Es gibt ja manchmal Schulungsprogramme,
dass die sagen, wir machen jetzt Schulungsoffensive,
und dann müssen die Leute sich allerdings
nochmal ein Jahr weiter verpflichten.
Aber wenn die das nicht machen,
dann können die sich auch nicht beschweren,
dass du nachher kündigst.
Und sie dürfen dir gar kein schlechtes Arbeitszeug ausstellen.
Dann kannst du sagen, das entspricht nicht meinen Aufgaben.
Und wenn sie nicht damit klarkommen,
sind sie selber daran schuld.
Also ganz im Ernst, ich gehe davon aus,
die stellen mir nicht mal ein schlechtes Arbeitszeugnis aus.
Also man kann ja zumindest mal
einen halbwegs professionellen Ablauf erwarten.
Und das ist es auch,
ein ordentliches Arbeitszeugnis auszustellen.
Also ich kenne jetzt den Laden natürlich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, kann doch nicht sein,
dass das richtige Drecksäcke sind.
Aber ich würde jetzt erstmal standardmäßig erwarten,
dass die sich ordentlich verhalten.
Ja, wenn es natürlich die Chance gibt,
dass du noch mehr Geld kriegst, dann...
Arbeitszeugnisse müssen wohlwollend sein.
Das heißt nicht, dass die wohlwollend geschrieben sein müssen.
Das heißt, dass die wohlwollend formuliert sein müssen.
Allerdings, du kannst auch ein
wohlwollend formuliertes Zeugnis machen.
Und du darfst ja nichts Negatives reinschreiben.
Und das ja auch da, dass es sich gut anhört.
Und jemand, der es kennt, weiß, dass es nicht gut gemeint ist.
Ja, also, ich würde erwarten,
die schreiben dir ein ordentliches Zeugnis,
so wie es eben den Tatsachen entspricht.
Und wenn sie das nicht machen,
beschwerste dich einfach, dass das Zeugnis,
so geht das nicht.
Ich würde jetzt aber gar nicht vorausgehen,
dass die standardmäßig da irgendwie
dir was reinwürgen wollen,
weil da eigentlich überhaupt kein Interesse dran.
Es wäre sogar aus heutiger Sicht total blöd,
sich für die Zukunft mit jemanden zu verkacken,
weil, wer weiß, vielleicht kommt es ja mal wieder.
Kann ja alles sein.
So, mal schauen, ob es U-Launcher
jetzt hinbekommen hat.
Ich sollte mal U-Launcher hier eintragen.
U-Launcher, wenn ich das so richtig schreiben kann.
U-Launcher, so.
Dann machen wir da noch R-Zeichen davor
und dann starten wir das nochmal neu.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das alles startet
und dann können wir weitermachen.
Genau, das denke ich mir auch.
Wenn die keine weiteren Bedingungen daran knüpfen,
dann müssen sie sich nicht wundern.
Also, bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber,
wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe,
ihr wisst ja, habe ich ja schon
mehrere Videos darüber gemacht,
bei dem Provider, da gab es ja Probleme.
Und unter anderem haben die irgendwann auch angefangen,
so Schulungsprogramme rauszuhauen,
allerdings mit ganz, ganz merkwürdigen Bedingungen.
Also, erstens solltest du dich ewige Zeiten
dran binden an den Arbeitgeber.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, wie lang es gewesen ist.
Es könnten sogar fünf Jahre gewesen sein
oder so etwas total weltfremd.
Es war auf jeden Fall viel zu viel.
Wahrscheinlich rechtlich fraglich,
ob es überhaupt zulässig ist.
Und die Schulungen waren auch
willkürlich ausgesucht für die Leute.
Man konnte sich die Schulungen nicht selbst aussuchen
und dann wollten sie noch,
dass du die Schulungen teilweise am Samstag machst.
Die hatten komplett den Arsch offen.
Ich habe das nicht unterschrieben
und ich würde es auch keinem empfehlen,
sowas zu unterschreiben.
Ich habe ein Video darüber gemacht, ja.
Okay, ich glaube, ich glaube jetzt,
jetzt hat es EU-Launcher gepackt,
dass man das Copy-Pasten ordentlich funktioniert.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert Copy-Pasten.
So, yes.
Aha.
X-Clip.
So, wie, wie, wie?
Hier, Minus E, Primary und Selection,
genau das will ich haben.
Und...
Meinetwegen auch noch, falls es das gibt.
Nee.
Was?
Ach so, das geht nicht.
Da drückt man da was ein.
Ernsthaft, ist das wieder so kompliziert,
einfach was ins Clipper zuzubringen?
So.
Und wenn man da jetzt ein paar Sachen drin hat,
wird das übertrieben langsam.
Also, ich hatte Performance-Probleme mit EU-Launcher
und mir hat auch generell dieses Menü hier nicht gefallen.
Und ich habe direkt einen Bug gefunden, Leute.
Passt mal auf.
Echo.
Span.
Keckel.
Ähm...
So, dann machen wir irgendwie Color...
Nee, Leute, ich brauch CSS.
Kann man einfach Color Blue machen?
Nee, Moment, Moment, Moment, Nee, Nee, Nee, Nee.
Style.
Und jetzt Color Blue, geht das so?
Und dann...
So.
Und ich habe einen Bug gefunden.
Guck mal.
Der eskept...
Das Ding eskept hat DML irgendwie nicht richtig.
Und wenn man Pech hat und macht das Multiline,
dann hast du teilweise in einem Clipboard
einen übergroßen blauen Text und sowas drinne.
Also, das ist irgendwie nicht der Weiß als letzter Schluss.
Ich bin damit nicht so ganz glücklich geworden.
Die Plugins an sich sind cool.
Wer braucht sowas?
Ein Clipboard-Manager.
Wie? Wir brauchen einen Clipboard...
Jeder braucht einen Clipboard-Manager.
Problem ist nur, wenn du jetzt sagst,
HTML-Example-Inline-Styles.
Problem ist jetzt, wenn du jetzt sowas hier zum Beispiel kop...
HTML-Zeug reinkopieren?
Hä?
Du copy-pastest halt Sachen,
da kann doch auch mal HTML drinne sein.
Ich würde mich eher fragen,
wer nicht ab und zu mal HTML copy-pastet.
Ich meine, wenn du irgendwelche Frontend-Sachen
entwickelst,
du pastest laufend irgendwelche HTML-Geschichten.
Manchmal geht's.
Manchmal geht's auch nicht.
Also manchmal mag er nicht.
Jetzt funktioniert's wieder.
Ich hab so nicht ganz rausgekriegt,
wann es nicht funktioniert.
Zumindest gab es noch ein paar mehr Punkte.
Was mich auch persönlich gestört hat,
ist, dass man den U-Launcher,
dass man das Copy-Menü nicht direkt aufmachen kann.
Weil ich benutze den Clipboard-Manager,
also ich kann es euch ja mal zeigen.
Warum müssen die Kiste aus?
Auf der alten Kiste.
Also ich hab mir das Ding
die letzten zwei Tage mal angeguckt.
Ich glaub, für mich ist das nix.
Und zwar,
Aha, Bing Image of the Day, alles klar.
Normalerweise benutze ich ja meinen Clipboard-Manager
total oft.
Ich mach den hier auf, paste irgendwas rein,
auf, next, sowieso.
Es geht sogar so weit,
dass wenn ich Sachen von einem Fenster
ins andere kopieren muss,
dann kopiere ich erst mal
drei, vier Dinger.
Und dann füge ich die woanders
mit dem Clipboard-Manager wieder ein.
Und ihr seht schon,
wie schnell das aufgeht.
Ich kann direkt,
ich drück eine Taste,
und das ist auf.
Das ist beim U-Launcher nicht so.
Beim U-Launcher muss ich immer
leer zeichnen, dann warten bis es lädt.
Man kann das Ganze natürlich ein bisschen
skripten. Ich könnte jetzt sagen, U-Launcher,
Toggle,
und, und
Sleep oder so,
Type C.
Ja, das könnte ich machen.
Und dann würde es das automatisch aufmachen,
aber
das ist
trotzdem lahm.
Ich will eine Taste,
ich will eine Taste drücken, dass
direkt mein
Menü aufgeht.
Dafür hat es andere
relativ coole Plugins.
Wir können es ja mal kurz
...
Dafür hat es ganz coole Plugins,
wo man
vieles schon von Haus aus bekommt.
Man bekommt eine Emoji
Search Funktion,
eine Calculator Funktion.
...
Und, dass es selbst relativ schwierig ist zu erweitern, es sei denn man baut eine Extension.
Man, es gibt, es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass man hier in Shortcuts was einträgt, das ist
aber bloß One Way, also du kannst da nur sagen Wiki und dann trägst du ein Text und
dann öffnet er das.
Du kannst jetzt nicht zum Beispiel ne Custom, da drüber Custom, also du kannst jetzt nicht
über diese Shortcuts beispielsweise Custom Text hier reinladen, was ich auch ein bisschen
doof finde von der Erweiterbarkeit.
Also ich glaube es wird bei mir doch kein New Launcher, sondern, sondern doch, sondern
doch wieder Rofi werden.
Also ich glaube es wird wieder das da, der sieht zwar standardmäßig ziemlich, ziemlich
kacke aus.
Also ich mein, das Ding sieht standardmäßig ziemlich, ziemlich müllig aus, hat noch nicht
mal, hat noch nicht mal Icons drinne, aber man kann sich das ja zusammenbauen.
Ich glaube, ich glaube da werde ich, werde ich mich jetzt mal ein bisschen, bisschen
dran austoben.
So, dann brauchen wir noch ne andere Sache, wir brauchen irgendwas um Notifications zu
empfangen und ich würd sagen, dann nehm ich das aller simpelste was es geht, dann nehm
ich den XFCE Notifier und fertig.
Taugt der Clipboard Manager in Windows was, ja das ist ganz ok, der ist ganz in Ordnung.
RofiThemes probiert, du meinst das GitHub, das da, ne Moment, ich weiß was du meinst.
Dieses mit 4000 Sternen, das war mir zu übertrieben.
Du meinst das hier gell, ne, Dunst sieht kacke aus und außerdem, wo brauch ich irgendwas
was Text anzeigen kann und sonst nix.
Was muss ich denn hier starten dafür überhaupt, äh, das da, kann das sein, das da, probier
wir mal, Notify Send Kackel, bam funktioniert, nice, gibt's da vielleicht auch ein paar,
ne, ach komm wir lassen es in der Default Config, ich will da nicht, will da nicht zu
viel gerade rumwursten.
Ja, das ist doch ganz in Ordnung, du hast das erste Mal den F-Sharp programmiert, nice.
Hab ich noch nie gemacht, ich hab noch nie, noch nie F-Sharped, so wir brauchen jetzt
erstmal ein gescheites Farbschema dafür, so wir editieren mal kurz unsere, Window Manager
Config zum starten, Ctrl D, so aber das können wir, das können wir schon mal alles rausschmeißen,
das brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht, Standard
Font ist Hack, ist eigentlich egal, weil ich den Font eh überschreibe, Null, so das brauchen
wir auch alles nicht, komm wir lassen, Mod D, da haben wir noch D-Menü drin, das wollen
wir nicht, wir wollen, Show Launchen, wenn ich jetzt Reload und Steuung D drücke, uah,
das sieht standardmäßig, das sieht standardmäßig schon ziemlich, ziemlich Paints-Champig aus,
F-Sharp ist einfacher als F-Sharp, ich kann weder zu dem einen noch zu dem anderen was
sagen.
Das ist das Funktionale der.NET-Gedöns, richtig, ich kann aber wie gesagt, das hab
ich noch nie, mich ausgesetzt, von Funktionalen Programmiersprachen hab ich bisher Abstand
gehalten.
Das Funktionalste war wahrscheinlich Rust bisher und Rust ist schon ziemlicher Pain
in The Bobes manchmal.
Auf der Arbeit hab ich mal ein bisschen Erlang gelesen und 2 Zeilen editiert, wir hatten
mal, kann nicht mehr was das war, war ein Erlang, hat nur aus Klammern bestanden.
Doch E-Lisp, ich hab E-Max, ich hab, ich hab E-Max früher selbst konfiguriert mit E-Lisp,
das war auch ganz furchtbar abartig.
Du kannst, also ich würd immer mal bei Berry Base gucken, Berry Base haben doch irgendwie
so nen Berry Base Club oder sowas, wo es manchmal welche gibt.
Was ich bei objektorientierter Programmieren nicht ganz hinbekomme ist Dateien verarbeiten,
verschiedene Typen oder Inhalt, hä, was hat das jetzt mit OOP zu tun?
Dateien verarbeiten, verschiedene Typen oder Inhalt, ich kann ihr nicht ganz folgen.
Du machst das alles immer in Funktion, das machst du in Objektorientierungen ja auch,
das heißt halt Methoden, aber im Prinzip, im Prinzip ist es ja genau das gleiche, nur
dass du es halt in ne Klasse reinschreibst.
Nee, F-Sharp ist genau, F-Sharp ist nicht, C-Sharp ist OOP, wobei C-Sharp mittlerweile
auch einiges Funktionale dabei hat.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, du kannst aber begeizt halt einfach mal die Diff, die Diff-Seite angucken
zwischen den Netzteilen, machen wir doch mal einfach, komm, wir sind mal, wir sind mal
nett.
Das hab immer, ich hab das Dark Power 13, oder?
Hab ich nicht das Dark, nee, ich hab ein Dark Power 12 drin, ok, was nun, Dark Power 13,
ah, das ist die ATX3 Variante, ah, deswegen ist das so teuer, weil es die ATX3 Variante
ist wahrscheinlich.
Pure Power 12 M, ok, guck mal mal, mein, wie edit man das jetzt noch mal, adden, oder
ich bin zu blöd, wie edit man das jetzt noch mal in ne Vergleichsliste, nicht zur Vergleichsliste,
steht sogar extra da, null, wir sollten es vielleicht auch mal lesen, so und was vergleichst
du, und dann willst du noch, das da, zum Vergleich, und wie macht man hier, so, jetzt können wir
mal gucken, wo der Unterschied ist, doch, du kannst auf Geizhals vergleichen, das ist
auch ganz gut, weil da kannst du Hersteller übergreifen, vergleichen, jetzt muss ja nicht
be quiet sein, so, Lüfter sind unterschiedlich und die Lautstärke ist unterschiedlich, das
ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht mal so wild, weil die Netzteile meistens nicht, sondern
nicht viel krach machen, eh, preislich dürfte das hier ne ganze Ecke, gelistet sind so ungefähr
gleich, ja, hätt ich das mal gewusst, dann hätt ich jetzt da ein ATX, ATX3 Netzteil
schon reingemacht, so, was ist denn hier der Unterschied, hier hast du ein bisschen
mehr, bisschen mehr, ne, du hast Sata drin, ah, das ist Titanium, oder, 80, 80 plus, ja,
das ist schon mal klar, ist das Titanium rated und das Gold rated, oder was ist denn das,
ne Gold, doch, ja, das ist Titanium rated, das ist Gold rated, ok, das ist schon mal
der eine Grund, warum es teurer ist, das macht für dich daheim mit der Kiste wahrscheinlich
gar keinen großen Unterschied, es macht allgemein keinen großen Unterschied, den ausschlaggebendsten
Punkt macht's wahrscheinlich, wenn du was ultra low power mäßiges dran betreiben
würdest, weil dann sind die, die sind ja überhaupt nicht effektiv, also Netzteile sind in der
Regel nie so effektiv, wenn du sie mit ganz wenig Last betreibst, aber wirklich viel,
viel, also, bis du das Geld gespart hast zwischen Titanium und dem, dem 80 plus Gold, dann
hast du, bis du den Netzteilpreis raus hast, das dauert, so, dann ist es, dann ist das
andere ein bisschen kleiner, ne, wobei, ne, das ist sogar größer, das ist ein bisschen
kleiner, du hast, du kriegst, kannst du wirklich ein bisschen mehr, hast ein bisschen mehr
Ampere, kannst insgesamt ein bisschen, wobei, eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied, vielleicht
wenn du super übertakten willst oder so, Anzahl der 12 Volt Schienen, ok, das ist irgendwie
so ein Spezialding, da hab ich keinen Plan von, was uns das genau sagen soll, also ehrlich
gesagt, ich seh jetzt nicht großartigen Unterschied, ich seh jetzt nicht den Unterschied, was
den Preis rechtfertigen würde, wo steht denn der Preis, hier guck mal, also was die 120
Euro Unterschied wirklich rechtfertigen würden, also ich hab das hier, warum ist ein Mines
mega teuer gerade, Dark Power 12000, warum ist ein Mines, was älter ist, teurer, oder
so teuer, wie das, achso, weil das meins quasi der Vorgänger von dem hier ist, verstehe,
verstehe, also ganz ehrlich, kannst hier wahrscheinlich auch ohne Probleme das da kaufen, wenns hier
um die 100 Euro geht, machts glaub ich keinen großen Unterschied, Max willst du die Programmierprüfung
erstes Semester in Uni machen, ist das in Java, in welcher Sprache, nee dann nicht,
dann bestimmt nicht, nee, nee, nee, nee, geh mehr weg, oh ich hab was ganz wichtiges
vergessen Leute, die haben noch keine ordentlich farbige LS Ausgabe, das geht ja nicht, das
ist das allerwichtigste was wir machen müssen, farbige LS Ausgabe, viel nicer gleich, umso
mehr Farben im Terminal umso besser, glaub da sind wir uns einig, auf der anderen Seite,
die klassische LS Ausgabe hat auch was, weil so siehts halt auf nem Remotesystem auch aus,
dann gewöhnt man sich daran, dass es halt auf nem Remotesystem so aussieht, also vielleicht
lasse ich auch das klassische LS, ach guck ich kann ja beides installiert lassen, so wir
wollten Rofi bisschen customisern, Rofi Tomorrow Theme GitHub, erstmal braucht es ein gescheites,
genau, erstmal braucht es ein gescheites Farbschema, ohne gescheites Farbschema geht nix, obviously,
jetzt machen die Ausrufezeichen davor, das ist doch ein Kommentar oder, ok also wir brauchen
Farbschema, ohne Farbschema tut es nix, wo kommen die Rofi Themes hin, local, share,
nee, Rofi Theme Location, user share, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, local, wo kommen die Dinger
hin, dot local, nee, ich bin mir relativ sicher, hier, local share, dots local share, local,
eh, wo müssen die Teile denn hin, wie wärs wenn sowas als erster Google Treffer vielleicht
auftauchen würde, Vestorm hat auch eine Statusbar, die man konfigurieren kann auch mal, nice,
kannst mal einen Link schicken, was mit der Musik los jetzt, deutlich angenehmer, was
wollte er wissen, ach hier direkt oben drüber, ja, Statusbar muss man mal suchen, Set Right
Status, das da, ah ok, na das ist nicht schlecht, also quasi wenn man nicht alles mit Tabs voll
spammt, dann kann man da sich noch was anzeigen lassen, na gut ich hab ja meine Statusbar
hier oben, ich wüsste gar nicht, also das Problem hatte ich in T-Max schon, ich wusste
gar nicht was ich da großartig mir anzeigen lassen soll, Dankeschön für den Sub, Grideo,
excellent, ich glaube die Themes müssen nach mkdir, local share, local share rofi oder sowas,
CD, local share, weget, so und jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob das angeboten wird, nein
natürlich nicht, dann muss es in Themes, ich rate jetzt einfach mal, man findet ja bei
Google nix gescheites, tomorrow da ist es, siehste easy, easy, so, can't read, no such
file or directory, ja ach, dann legs halt an, wo ist das Problem man, dann legs halt
an, eh wieso, da ist es doch, so und jetzt können wir das ein bisschen customize, weil
ganz im ernst, so siehts halt kacke aus, ich mein es gibt schlimmeres, aber hübsch ist
nur echt was anderes, es fehlen schon mal die ganzen Modi die man auswählen kann und
sonstigen Dingen, also, so, rofi config example, haben wir da irgendein Beispiel, config md,
hier, powers, excellent, zack zack zack zack zack, ne das brauchen wir nicht, modes, ok
modes, was wollen wir für modes haben, window run ssh, ne ssh brauchen wir nicht, sollte
der nicht eigentlich jetzt alles mögliche anzeigen, show, sollte ich nicht hier unten
jetzt eigentlich den leister haben zum auswählen, all die musik ist mir zu anstrengend, ich
brauch doch wieder relaxing, wow wow wow wow, relaxing mario, oder so, ja auch gut, auch
wunderbar, so, ah jetzt, gleich, gleich viel besser, so, sollte der nicht eigentlich,
die ganzen Modi anzeigen, modes, wir fangen auf jeden fall mal nicht mit window an, sondern
mit drun und dann run, dann mein wegen window, wobei ich den windows switcher eh nicht verwende,
ok gut, jetzt können wir nämlich da drüber anwendungen starten, zum beispiel firefox,
jetzt brauchen wir noch was mit icons, show icons true, das brauchen wir, das ist schon
mal viel besser, ja guck mal, jetzt siehts schon mal nicht gar so kacke aus, oder, das
sieht doch jetzt schon mal besser aus als vorher, so, dann nehmen wir noch so viel font,
deswegen hab ich den nämlich installiert, weil ich finde das sieht ganz gut aus, irgendwie
medium 16, was jetzt, ja das sieht doch jetzt schon mal deutlich besser aus als vorher,
oder, kann man doch direkt, kann man sich das doch fast schon geben, ach hier kann man
zwischen den Modi umschalten, da hätt ich aber gerne nen button unten, weil ich merke
mir doch nicht alle Modi, vor allem ist das, was ist das, control tap, da denk ich im leben
nicht dran, dass man control tap und control, control shift tap, wer zum teufel kann control
shift tap drücken, ohne sich die finger zu verbiegen, probiert das mal aus leute, ich
tue dir der kleine finger wie, control shift tap, nicht aus versehen auf caps lock kommen,
control shift tap, das ist zum geier, wer hat's, egal, die default tastenbelegung, na
control shift t zum beispiel für neue taps ist vollkommen in ordnung, das ist das gleiche
wie im browser, also im browser benutze ich so gut wie nie control shift t, da drück
ich immer t, für neuen tap, und control shift t zum alten tap wieder aufmachen, hallo was,
das brauchst du ja nicht so oft, was, control shift tap, ne, control shift tap kann man ab
und zu mal drücken, wenn man den tap wieder aufmachen will, aber ansonsten, irgendjemand
hat gesagt, dings, was, minus, minus, dump, konfig oder so, ne, minus, achso, aha, gucke
mal da, ok, das ist natürlich praktisch, das ist natürlich praktisch, dann sieht man, was
es gibt, dann sieht man, was es an konfig gibt, kann man uns das gleich anschauen, das ist
ganz ganz nützlich, aber sieht jetzt ja schon mal ganz ok aus, so, wir brauchen auf jeden
fall show icons, show icons, ne, haben wir ja, icons theme default ist in ordnung, ja, das
ist auch ok, können sich wieder nicht entscheiden, wie laut die musik sein soll, ok, ok, ok,
ok, kleiner finger, ring finger, mittelfinger, ja, so mach ich das auch, ich drücke, ich
drücke control shift komplett mit dem kleinen finger und dann drücke ich mit dem, mit dem
mittelfinger tap, aber, eh, control shift t ist ja in ordnung, das geht ja im browser
nicht, aber, aber control shift tap ist eklig, so, was brauchen wir denn sonst noch, macht
man das theme oben oder macht man das theme unten, man macht das bestimmt unten, dass
das, die default config richtig greift, ok, das ist eigentlich so in ordnung, ich glaub
vielmehr, so, jetzt bin ich grad noch am überlegen, wie kriegt man das jetzt noch mal hin, dass
man unten ein menü hat, so zum auswählen, jetzt, das ist bestimmt so ne, so ne theming
geschichte, oh, hier rein, was haben wir denn hier, lgb, oh, können wir den hintergrund
transparent machen, seck, das muss ich mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert, hey Leute,
wir können hier, transparent background, pogu, das aller, das allerwichtigste, das aller,
allerwichtigste, das brauchen wir, transparent background, ne, eigentlich, eigentlich brauchen
wir das nicht, das sieht, das sieht massiv scheiße aus mit transparent background, vor
allem, wenn wir das hier so aufmachen, dann erkennste gar nichts, ne, das ist nix, das
müssen wir wieder rückgängig machen, das sieht nix aus, so, was haben wir hier, text
prompt, Leute, ich frag mich ernsthaft, wie ich da
unten, ich weiß, dass geht, man kann hier unten anzeigen lassen, was es, was es für
Modi gibt, da bin ich aber nicht sicher, ob man das im theme machen muss, oder ob das,
ob das eine config option ist, show mode tabs, oder irgendwie sowas, browser tab switching,
was, firefox tabs, gibt was um firefox tabs zu durchsuchen, das ist natürlich pogu, das
brauche ich, oh, das ist nice, ach, man braucht, na, das ist natürlich doof, man braucht eine
browser extension dafür, ah gut, kann ich mir vorstellen, die browser haben da wahrscheinlich
keine API irgendwie drauf zuzugreifen, aber das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich cool,
wenn das geht, lachow, danke schön für den sub, das wäre natürlich nice, wenn man damit
seine browser tabs filtern könnte, wir können auch noch mal ein anderes cursor theme gleich
machen, so, gibt es jetzt da irgendwas sinnvolles, was ich noch machen kann, wie mache ich denn
die icons größer, einmal kurz schenken, wie mache ich denn die icons größer, glaube,
da muss man irgendwo hier rein, was haben wir denn jetzt, icon, text, icon, hier, und dann,
sowas wie width oder sowas, nope, size, kann das sein, 80, also size 2em, ah, guck mal,
jetzt, noch besser, noch besser, jetzt erkennt man wenigstens richtig was, jetzt ist es vielleicht
schon fast ein bisschen zu groß, oder, jetzt brauchen wir ein bisschen spacing, spacing
mal 5px, sonst siehts dumm aus, ja, und vielleicht nicht ganz so groß, vielleicht nicht ganz
so groß, aber 1,5em, damit kann ich leben, das ist doch vollkommen, ey, der text ist
nicht richtig aligned, wie geht, dark side, danke schön für den sub, der text ist nicht
richtig aligned, hör mal bloß auf, aber damit, damit bin ich jetzt erstmal, damit kann ich
leben, das ist ok, damit kann ich leben, wunderbar, ja, jetzt brauchen wir noch green clip als
clipboard manager dafür, dann bin ich glaube ich erstmal zufrieden, so wie das launcher
menü ist, zack, zack, ähm, wie ging das, sample clipboard manager, ah, config, hier,
modi, so, das muss man jetzt glaube ich in die e3 config hauen, so, also quasi das da,
dass wir jetzt minus p machen, und dann solltet mein clipboard manager automatisch, automatisch
launchen, ja, aber der text ist nicht richtig aligned, alter sieht das hässlich aus, monkaS,
so, mal ein bisschen anderes zeug copypasten, ob das funktioniert, ok, ah, der andere crempel
läuft noch, der u launcher kram läuft noch, ok, dann ist natürlich kein wunder, dass es
nicht funktioniert, kurz ausmachen und wieder an, moin intense hunter, so, menü, menü,
soll jetzt mal schauen, ob copypaste funktioniert, immer noch nicht, warum nicht, muss ich green
clip nochmal von hand starten, vielleicht, dass das funktioniert, just, just forehead,
wahrscheinlich muss ich das nochmal von hand starten, komm mal, gucken wir mal, ob das
funktioniert, so, firefox aufmachen, ah, jetzt, jetzt hat das gecheckt, jetzt hat das gecheckt,
guck, null, jetzt geht das alles, sehr schön, jetzt habe ich auch ein clipboard menü, was
schnell lädt, so mag ich das, jetzt müssen wir noch nach config, oh, wo war das config
green clip und dann die max history 9999 einträge, ich brauche history as fuck, enable image
support, konnte, man konnte noch irgendwie sagen, dass der beides überschreibt, sync,
primary, use, primary selection, ah, nee, hat er schon, wie oft das schon Passwörter
geleakt mit dem clipboard manager, glaube gar nicht, passt da immer auf, was natürlich
mega nice wäre, irgendeine Funktion, dass ich das clipboard disablen könnte, also, dass
ich beispielsweise sagen könnte, dass man hier unbedingt einen icon hat, wo man drauf
klicken kann, dann clipboard, clipboard ausmacht, das wäre natürlich enorm praktisch, noch
eben mit irgendeinem icon, dass ich es ordentlich erkenne, aber wir brauchen jetzt erstmal
ein gescheites, gescheites Mauszeiger-Theme, das sieht doch kacke aus, was ist denn, was
ist denn ein gescheites, ich habe aktuell nur das default, default cursor-Theme, was
gibt es denn, was gibt es denn für gescheite cursor-Themes, irgendwas, was nicht ganz so,
ganz so billig aussieht, Kapitane-Cursors, wie sieht dann Kapitane-Cursors aus, ist bestimmt
irgend so ein Apple-Rip-Off, oder, bei dem Name, Kapitane-Cursors, ok ja, es ist so,
es ist ein bisschen Apple-Rip-Off, ist aber nicht schlimm, sieht ganz gut aus, probier
was mal aus, Kapitane-Cursors, richtig schreiben wäre ganz nice, Starship-Themes, ich brauche
jetzt irgendwas buntes, Themes, Resets, da gab es doch irgendwas, was passt her, KappaPride-Prompt,
das ist ein pures Arsch, das ist doch mal was, das sieht tatsächlich ganz gut aus,
muss ich sagen, also ich bin erst positiv überrascht, das sieht mit dem Farbschema von
der Konsole auch gar nicht so übel aus, das da oben müsste jetzt halt, das müsste halt
farblich noch dazu passen, das sieht aber gar nicht mal, vor allem mit dem Herzchen
drinne und es sieht gar nicht mal so übel aus, behalte das, ja, sieht gut aus, ne, so
Kapitane-Cursors, Maus-Kapitane, weiser Cursor oder dunkler Cursor, wahrscheinlich ist ein
schwarzer Cursor gar nicht so schlau, weil ich habe ja überall ziemlich, ziemlich Dark-Theme,
wir probieren mal, wir probieren es mal aus, also wie sieht es mit schwarzen Cursors aus,
wie sie klein oder, aber schwarze Cursor sind hier schon ziemlich schwierig drauf zu
erkennen, ja, machen wir mal den weißen Cursor, bisschen klein ist es auch, wir machen das
gleich mal ein bisschen größer, machen das gleich mal ein bisschen, ok, den Cursor sieht
man deutlich besser, deutlich besser, sieht man, sieht man, bisschen klein ist es allerdings,
glaub dazu muss ich, was machen wir mal für eine Size 32, eine muss ich jetzt immer dazu
neu starten, dass es funktioniert, ja, das ist doch schon mal ganz gut hier, guck mal,
das passt doch, guck mal, das sieht doch jetzt wirklich gar nicht so übel aus, das passt
auch, guck mal, das, alter, guck mal, wie gut das passt, Leute, die Höhe eines, einer,
einer Zeile im Terminal ist exakt so groß wie das, wie das Select, wie das Select-Cursor,
als wäre es, als wäre es auf den Pixel genau fast, der andere Seite ist es, glaub ich,
gar nicht so gut, da sehe ich nicht, wo ich bin, wobei doch, doch scannt schlecht, ein
bisschen, ein bisschen kleiner, komm, also eins kleiner, komm, machen wir mal 30, falls
es überhaupt geht, falls es nicht 32, so ein Default, so ein Default wird, ne, ok, es geht
nicht, jetzt wird er kleiner Cursor, schmoll, schmoller Cursor, Linux, guck mal mal, was
sind denn da so die Fault-Sizes, ok, Session is broken, Linux, Cursor-Sizes, 24, 32, ok,
es gibt nur 24, 32, 48, naja, ok, warum ist sowas eigentlich nicht schon in Vector-Font,
äh, nicht in Vector-Font, in Vector-Bild, so, seriously, warum ist der Cursor einfach
noch nur in speziellen Größen verfügbar, warum ist der nicht Vector-Cursor, das ist,
das kann X wahrscheinlich nicht, weil, weil X muss ja den Cursor malen, X ist wahrscheinlich
zu alt, das kann keine Vector-Bilder malen und dementsprechend auch keine Cursor, aber
das finde ich schon mal ganz gut, das hat was, da sieht man schon den Cursor hier im Terminal,
hier ist es nicht so klein, ähm, das ist nice und, und man sieht ganz gut, auf diesem,
weil ich ja überall Dark Theme eingestellt habe, sieht man auch ganz gut den, hier einmal
diesen Selektor und dann halt hier oben halt den Cursor überall, wie bekommt man so Farben
im Terminal, nutzt du das gleiche wie du, welche, welche Farben meinst du, das hier,
dass das Terminal insgesamt so aussieht, das hier ist mein Farbschema, du kannst aber auch
einfach hier sowas laden, du kannst, du kannst auch einfach irgendwie ein Colorscheme laden,
aber das, ach die Regenbogen, das hier, das hier, das ist Starship, Starship RS Starship
und das ist das, ähm, Preset Pastel Powerline, wobei man sagen muss, Starship ist eher was
zum Selbstkonfigurieren, weil das hat nur drei richtige, oder vier, vier, vier richtige
Presets, der Rest ist halt was mit Symbolen ohne Symbole, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass
es wahrscheinlich auf GitHub ein bisschen mehr gibt, naja also, nur weil eine Software vor
40 Jahren erfunden wurde, heißt ja nicht, dass sie nicht mittlerweile angepasst werden
kann, ich meine es ist ja nicht so, als wäre X 40 Jahre alt, in dem Sinn, dass seit 40
Jahren keiner mehr dran was gemacht hat, ich meine keiner hat Bock an X was zu machen,
das kann ich auch verstehen, X11 programmieren muss wahrscheinlich Abfakt des Todes sein,
hätte ich auch wirklich keinen Bock drauf, so ich brauche mein Notizprogramm, wobei
nein, nein, nein, nein, App Image brauchen wir, denn das App Image ist wenigstens nicht
zu mit Selbstkompilieren verbunden, wenn ich das hier installiere, dann muss ich bestimmt
selbst kompilieren, probieren wir gleich mal aus, man könnte ja auch ganz feifettmäßig
das Bild von den Cursors einer Vektor Grafik nach Größe gehen, das meine ich doch, du
gibst an Größe 37 und dann, ach so meinst du das, du meinst, dass der on the fly dann
PNGs oder so draus macht, was das unterstützt, ja das, das weiß ich nicht, guck mal mal,
ich kann euch übrigens auch was cooles zeigen, was ich gebaut habe, gehen wir mal gucken,
user share, wo sind denn die Cursor, hier, Cursor, nee, Pacman minus QL, Cursors, hier
user share, user, ok, user share icons Kapitane Cursors, Cursors, die gibt es gar nicht in
unterschiedlichen Größen, was ist denn da, was, ah, das sind alles links, ok, das skaliert
X wohl irgendwie und wenn X das skaliert, dann kann man da wahrscheinlich nichts dran
machen, X Cursor Sizes, Sizes A 24, es gibt, seriously, es gibt ernsthaft nur diese, ok,
Custom Cursor Sizes, how to enlarged mouse, ok, das klingt schon fast nach Viagra Sperm
so ein bisschen, exzellente Präsentation, alles klar, exzellent, alles klar, da weißt
du Bescheid, sowieso, verstehe, verstehe, XZRoot, mein Gott, das ist wieder eine Wissenschaft
für sich, so einen Mouse Cursor zu resizen, the default exists, das ist ein Font, ok, das
ist mir zu Sixhead, das ist mir zu Sixhead, den Cursor zu resizen, X Cursor, wie sieht
so ein X Cursor im Source aus, yes, ah, obviously, ja wie, das kann das so nicht anzeigen, auch
kein loadable image, was ist hier, kann VLC das, Leute, wenn VLC das nicht anzeigen kann,
VLC kann alles anzeigen, ich will, ich will, dass VLC mein Cursor anzeigt, nein, natürlich
geht das nicht, oh, oh, VLC ist der Meinung, das ist ein abspielbares Audio, ich glaube
so ein X11 Cursor Format verwirrt jede Software, how to get available, you can use X Cursor
viewer to look inside the Cursor file and see what sizes are available, aha, ok, das
ist Fivehead, das müsste man dann quasi, ich glaube ich lasse das mit dem, mit dem Custom
Cursor, ich hätte den Cursor gerne ein bisschen kleiner, also Cursor ist ok, aber dieses
Selection Ding hätte ich gerne ein bisschen kleiner, weil das ist schon, das ist schon
sehr fett dafür, ne, X Cursor Viewer, ok, wenn es sowas nicht als Arch Package gibt,
dann kannst du es, dann kannst du es vergessen, GitHub, X Cursor Viewer, brauchen wir das,
ne, ich glaube das lassen wir bleiben, bestes Cursor Seam Open Zone Cursor, zeig mal her,
das ist der, das ist der Windows, das sieht aus wie der Windows Zeiger oder, also der
Standard sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Windows Zeiger, echt, wir können mal ausbringen,
Open Zone, Open Zone Cursor Files, ja dann, probieren wir mal aus, wir haben ja sonst
nichts zu tun, die File sind zu klein und dick, gucken wir mal, gucken wir gleich mal,
erstmal kurz, erstmal kurz den Cursor selbst kompilieren, so, Icon Seam, Cursor Seam,
oh, oh, was haben wir denn hier, Black Slim, ach guck mal, den gibt es in, den gibt es
in Pepega, also in Pay-Per-Fat und in nicht Pay-Per-Fat, Fire, Ice White, machen wir mal
den, findest du es gar nicht mal so übel, Close, das ist eins zu eins der gleiche, der
sieht sehr Windows Mausig aus, gell, hier, das ist original die Windows Maus Leute, erzählt
mir nichts, das ist original die Windows Maus man, und den gibt es anscheinend nur auch
in einer Größe, Oxygen Cursors, warum sind das, warum sind die Dinge alle so alt, oh
ne, die kenne ich von früher noch, ne, die gefallen mir nicht, ich fand den, den ich
als Freund hatte gar nicht so übel, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, den Windows Maus Cursor
unter Linux, der verwirrt mich, dann habe ich lieber den anderen, weil das ist doch
jetzt, das ist doch im Leben keine 32er Size, wir machen, wir machen wir das andere Cursor
Theme hier, Kapitane, save, open, zone, ne wie ist das Ding, Cursor, ach du Scheiße,
ich habe vergessen, ach X-Cursor, X-Cursor Open Zone, exellent, so, wieder alles weg
und noch einmal neu starten und jetzt haben wir wieder den Mac OS Fake Cursor, das ist
Arch by the way, selbstverständlich, was soll es sonst sein, by the way, natürlich by the
way Arch, ach wir lassen es jetzt einfach so, glaub damit kann ich leben mit diesem Cursor,
wobei ich die Idee, vom Ansatz her gar nicht so blöd finde, den gleichen Cursor zu verwenden
wie unter Linux und wie unter Windows, dann hat man halt was gewohntes, aber ganz im Ernst,
ich habe es ja absichtlich so, dass es sich ein bisschen unterscheidet, also es ist mir
lieber, ist mir deutlich lieber, also das ist auch schon mal ganz nice, jetzt haben wir
einen ordentlichen Cursor, jetzt haben wir ein ordentliches Theme, das Terminal, ach
Leute, das allerwichtigste, ganz vergessen, ganz vergessen, wo habe ich es denn, passt
mal auf, das hier, das wichtigste Feature ever, was ich gefunden habe.
Ganz essenziell, transparenter, leicht transparenter Background, so und jetzt bräuchte man eigentlich
noch ein bisschen Blur im Hintergrund, oder das wäre natürlich der richtige Premium,
so ein bisschen Blur im Hintergrund, da gehen wir mal hier, config, pi, com, wie macht man
hier Blur, Blur, how to use transparency effects, jawoll, zeig mir wie es geht, Blur, alles
klar, Pepo ist geblurrt, besser, komm mal her, geblurter Pepo im Hintergrund, so mag
ich das, ihr erkennt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig, guckt mal, jetzt ist er, da
ist er, blurrt Pepo, ok, das muss man machen, muss man auch setzen, so, besser, besser geblurter
Pepo am Start, oh jetzt ist es da oben auch geblurrt, das ist natürlich doof, wieso
ist das so, ich glaube das liegt daran, erstens weil es ein Rolling Release ist und wenn man
auf dem Desktop in Linux hat, glaube ich zumindest, dass viele Leute gut finden, wenn man die
neuesten Packages hat und weil du es halt mit am besten customisieren kannst.
Alles riesen Software Auswahl und Customisability würde ich sagen, wie kriege ich jetzt geblurter
da oben jetzt raus, guck mal jetzt ist meine Leiste hier oben auch geblurrt, das ist natürlich
doof, pi, com, exclude from Blur, how to remove Blur.pi.com ads around Firefox, exellent,
class Firefox, ne, ne, ne, ne, das muss einfach angehen, remove pi.com blur from BlankDoc,
ok, BlurBackground Exclude, BlurBackground, oh ich bin im falschen Fenster, BlurBackground
Exclude, aha, siehste, ohne Scheiß Stag Overflow wieder, Stag Overflow Saved, so jetzt machen
wir das zurück auf irgendwie 96 oder so, 97 und jetzt schimmert, guck mal Leute, jetzt
schimmert der Pepo so leicht geblurrt im Hintergrund durch, so ist das doch nice, guck
mal, leicht geblurrter Pepo, sodass es nicht stört im Terminal, es ist eigentlich kaum
zu sehen, aber wenn man drauf achtet sieht man es, so ist das nice, das gefällt mir,
Poggers, extrem Poggers, Rainbow Poggers, das gefällt mir, das ist schick, damit kann
ich, damit kann ich leben, das lassen wir so, also wir haben ein Copy Paste Menü, die
Schrift ist ja nicht ganz zentriert, da muss ich mal gucken, meine Notizsoftware ist jetzt
auch drauf, oh was ist das, Monkeys, warum ist die broken, was jetzt, Moment, warum ist
das, warum ist das broken, welchen Clip Art Manager, das ist Green Clip, weil das gute
Profi Integration hat, warum spackt das manchmal rum, hier was ist da, kann ich das denn einfach
alles löschen, Delete, Delete, Minimize, Appearance, das spackt rum, wo kann man jetzt
noch mal einstellen, dass der automatisch sich minimiert, wo ist es versteckt, Application,
Minimized, Showtray Icon, guck mal, guck mal, das ist kaputt, ups, hab ich geschlossen
als Versetzung, irgendwas ist hier kaputt dran, irgendwas stimmt mit der Darstellung
nicht, guck mal, Moment, warte mal, Notebooks, Kacke, New Note, ja das ist kaputt, guck mal,
was ist da kaputt dran, was ist da los, warum ist das broken, was soll das, was ist hier,
da ist irgendwas kaputt, auf jeden Fall gerade, vielleicht liegt es auch an der VM, aber ich
hab es schon ewig auch in der VM laufen, guck mal, da ist irgendwas kaputt, meckert das
Ding hier vielleicht, hat das irgendwas, das muss man bestimmt, das muss man bestimmt
im, muss man bestimmt GPU Acceleration deaktivieren, dann geht es wahrscheinlich, Disabled GPU,
Turn Off Hardware Acceleration, Support, genauer, oh, das ist ja, das ist immer sehr hilfreich,
das Topic war Automatically Closed, geil, das ist immer super hilfreich, solche Feedback
forren, wo das Feedback einfach automatisch geschlossen wird nach 60 Tagen, Hardware Acceleration,
das geht bestimmt irgendwie, kann man No Sandbox oder sowas machen, vielleicht geht das dann,
No Sandbox, das ist ja, das ist ja irgendein Chrome, irgendein Chrome Problem, Disabled
Hardware Acceleration, Disabled Hardware Acceleration, das ist bestimmt ein Elektronenproblem im
Zusammenhang mit dem VM-Driver, hier, guck mal, Computer Screen Freezing, Disabled Hardware
Acceleration, ok, ja, wie sag bloß, da gibt es nix, da gibt es Seriously, es gibt keine
Möglichkeit, die Hardware Acceleration auszumachen, ja Elektron alleine bringt ja nix, die müssen
das ja supporten, die müssen den Kommandozeilen-Switcher durchreichen, das ist natürlich doof, in meiner
alten VM funktioniert es aber, also, hab ich sie überhaupt hier installiert, genau, hier,
by the way, guck, kein Problem, in der alten VM funktioniert es, ups, wenn ich das richtige,
richtige Fenster nehme, alles ok, das muss irgendwas im Zusammenhang mit dem neuen Treiber
und Vmware sein, ja, ok, oh, oh, oh, oh, MonkaS, MonkaS, was jetzt, das hab ich ja noch nie
geschafft, Vmware zu crashen, also läuft aber noch, easy, weil die Vmware starten nach
all den Änderungen, ich hab ja gar keine großartigen Änderungen gemacht, also nix,
was irgendwie Grafikkardware oder so betrifft, ok, es gibt keine Möglichkeit, ok, ich hab
noch, ich hab noch eine, eine Fiveheader-Idee, da glaub ich aber nicht, dass dies funktioniert,
aber man kann, man kann, vielleicht kann ich ne, ähm, hier, Linux Force OpenGL-Version,
man kann, genau, man kann per Environment-Variable irgendwie, genau, sowas hier, man kann per
Environment-Variable die OpenGL-Version runtersetzen und vielleicht, wenn ich die OpenGL-Version
runtersetze, dann rendert es noch, aber nicht in dem neuen Modus, der verbuggt ist im neuen
Vmware, das könnte natürlich sein, hallo, please ladenseite, also was haben wir denn,
Version 2.0, ok, wir nehmen, wir nehmen einfach mal das älteste, was es gibt, export, gleich
zwei, ne, zwei, 2.1, mal gucken, ob es dann überhaupt noch startet, startet noch, zeigt
aber gar kein Inhalt mehr, läuft eigentlich der E3 auf Templos, selbstverständlich, was
sonst, ok, mit so einer alten OpenGL-Version geht gar nichts mehr, alles klar, sehr gut,
nice, was, was können wir als nächstes probieren, ich richte gerade meine Linux-VM weiter ein,
und wir haben Probleme mit Rendering von manchen Anwendungen in der VM, wie sieht es denn mit
OpenGL 3.0 aus, vielleicht geht es damit, ach guck mal da, da gibt es jetzt auch keine,
da gibt es auch keine Grafikfehler, easy, einfach alles hier OpenGL-Version runterstellen, ok,
ab wann, ab wann fängt es, ok, 3.2, ab da geht es bestimmt los kaputt zu gehen, ja, ok,
da geht es kaputt, 3.2 geht es kaputt, 3.0 und 3.1 und so gehen anscheinend noch, exzellent,
gut zu wissen, was haben wir sonst noch, Compat, hast du mal nach, ah libgl-allways-software,
sehr gute Idee, sehr gute Idee, unset, das wusste ich nicht, dass das geht, erstmal
gucken, ob es jetzt wieder kaputt ist, ja, direkt Brocken, man sieht es glücklicherweise
schon direkt beim Start, wenn es Brocken ist, weil es dann irgendwelche Farbfehler hier
oben gibt, Export und dann was, True oder 1 oder was muss man da, ach nicht gleich 1,
das ist besser, eine ältere OpenGL-Version setzen oder generell auf Software-Rendering
forsten, letztendlich ist es egal, läuft beides, wahrscheinlich ist Software-Rendering
in dem Fall besser, falls sie irgendwas neues benutzen und das mit der alten Version abkackt,
ältere Version sollte schneller sein, ja das stimmt, aber ganz ehrlich bei dieser Notiz-Software
ist glaub nicht so das Problem, dass ich die Performance, den Performance-Impact so
sehr spüre zwischen Software-Rendering oder, komm wir machen einfach so, so, tragen wir
das mal ein, neues Shortcut, Minus, Plus, J, jetzt, ich glaub ich muss das eher so
Quoten, sonst wird das nichts, alles klar, Reload, Error, warum, wo ist das Problem,
ist Plus J schon belegt irgendwo, ah, Change Focal, das brauch ich nicht, das mach ich
mit den Pfeiltasten, J, das ist ja auch Desktop, aha, funktioniert, Shortcut zu, Shortcut auf
und ohne Grafikfehler, Porgas, was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen dem App-Image und
Desktop, muss ich das hier selbst kompilieren, dass es funktioniert, oh ja, muss ich, never
mind, machen wir jetzt nicht, also selbst kompilieren bei der Node.js Anwendung ist ja eh ein Anführungszeichen,
ne, dann nehm ich lieber das App-Image und setz Niedrige Auf und GL-Version, so, ok,
jetzt kann ich Windows-Taste J drücken und es geht mein Notizprogramm auf, nice, so mag
ich das, so können wir das lassen, was brauchen wir denn sonst noch, ich glaube wir nähern
uns so langsam aber sicher, der Vollendung, ach ne, ZSH muss ja umgeschaltet werden noch,
so, das weiß ich nicht, so, kann man das immer nicht merken, Pedersa, 123456, Massive Passwort,
das macht man so, das macht man auch so, das macht man einmal pro Installation, äh, Create,
ja, ja, ja, Create-Dings, ZSH, ok, GitHub, Dot-Files, da muss ich mal zumindest die basic
Sachen von der alten ZSH rüber kopieren, weil das alles mir neu ausdenken, hab ich
keinen Bock drauf, wir werden aber die Hälfte wahrscheinlich rauslöschen, also, erste
mal hier oben den Kabel, das ist gut, das ist gut, das ist gut, das ist auch ok, Prompt
kommt weg, History ist gut, ich bin ganz bescheiden mit der History, kann man die History nicht
auf Null stellen, dann ist es Unlimited, geht das nicht mittlerweile, dass man Hists heißt,
auf Null stellt und dann ist es Unlimited History, ne, ok, ja das geht, aber Hists heißt
Null geht nicht, in den Ansible Playbook, na, man kann es auch, ja, aber ne, in dem Fall,
ihr hättet mal schon machen können, aber wozu, Maximum of Dumbass, if this is metal, it
is not implicit, hä, das verstehe ich nicht, aber es gibt wahrscheinlich kein Unlimited,
aber das reicht auch, ich mein das sind, äh, Moment, wie viel Null, eins, zwei, drei, vier,
fünf, sechs, sieben, also, eine Milliarde, ne, zehn Millionen, zehn Millionen Zeilen
in der History, das ist in Ordnung, vielleicht kann das Tethers Haar auch, ich mein es wird
praktisch gesehen keinen Unterschied machen, ob zehn Millionen oder minus eins, aber wenn
schon hätte ich gleich minus eins reingeschrieben, wenn das geht, so, das Shell Seam brauchen
wir nicht, das brauchen wir auch nicht, das könnten wir mal lassen, da weiß ich nicht
mehr, was ich mir dabei gedacht hab, das schmeißen wir auch weg, ne, Top auf Hardtop linken lassen
wir da, das da brauchen wir auch nicht mehr, das brauchen wir auch nicht, das können wir
lassen, T-Mark verwenden wir an der Stelle lokal nicht mehr, Path brauchen wir auch
nicht und das brauchen wir auch nicht, so, wir brauchen noch unser Starship und den ganzen
anderen Krempel nehmen wir mal mit, Alias, Zack, Bash, E, ja, ok, Starship, Prompt brauchen
wir an der Stelle nicht, Curlwetter, wunderbar, allerwichtigste überhaupt, genau, Repos,
Pript, Spindle, du dumm, sieht ganz sinnvoll aus, oh, was ist kaputt, was ist kaputt,
hab ich irgendwo was mit kopiert oder Zeile 45, ah, ja, ok, kaum macht man es richtig,
dann funktioniert das auch schon, guckt der Pepo guckt uns zu im Hintergrund, da ist er,
der guckt da, der beobachtet uns, genau, so, jetzt habe ich so ordentlich geschält, jetzt
drehe ich nicht mehr durch, jetzt habe ich auch ordentlich gescherte History und sowas,
bei Bash habe ich hier wieder den Anfall gekriegt, das muss jetzt wirklich mal sein, so, Notizprogramm
lauschen, wunderbar, ähm, ich würde jetzt ja mal ein Joplin noch, also nicht mein Rohr
viel noch ein bisschen weiter customisieren, aber ich habe gerade echt keinen Bock auf
irgendwelches Design Kram hier, das muss jetzt erstmal so reichen, zumal der Kram hier auch
nicht richtig aligned ist, was habe ich an Shad Bash genommen, ZSH, Zschel, kann man
ja aussprechen, wie man will, ist mir viel angenehmer, so, ähm, dann, lass mal überlegen,
was brauchen wir, was brauchen wir noch für Dinger, Clipboard, ach, wir könnten mal dieses
Autosuggestion Ding ausprobieren, GitHub Autosuggestion, das da, gibt es doch bestimmt,
Autosug, gibt es als Package und wie Insta, Exa habe ich schon installiert, aber ich habe
es noch nicht irgendwie gelingt oder so, oder Alias gemacht, weil ich bin mir noch unschlüssig,
ob ich es wirklich wieder verwenden will, was braucht man jetzt, Source, Source, irgendwie
muss das gehen, Source hier, Zschings Autosuggestion, LSD, Modern LS, ok, das hört sich jetzt nach
Monkratos an, Next Gen LS Command, ist das denn auch Blazingly Fast Written in Rust,
ich hoffe mal, sieht so aus, ok, dann ist nice, dann ist nice, ok, dann probieren wir das auch
mal aus, mit Icons, na und es ist direkt kompatibel zu den LS Befehlen, das ist nämlich bei Exa,
ging mir das ein bisschen auf den Keks, dass es nicht 1 zu 1 kompatibel zu den LS Aliasen
ist, kann man, ich gette, dass eines der Haupt, ein hauptcooles Faktor ist, dass das Ding Terminal
Icons hat, aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde die Terminal Icons irgendwie irritierend,
chat, ihr könnt, wir verg- guck mal, wir vergleichen das mal, also, was findet ihr
eben die Fall schöner, man kann das ja sicherlich konfigurieren, das da, das da, wobei das ein
Zettel ist, das muss ich in Bash machen, weil ansonsten, das da, oder, ups, oder, ah fuck
jetzt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das gescheit resize hier, oder, tja, kann man nicht machen
jetzt, und meine Vor- und Zurück-Taste geht auch nicht, so, also, ja man erkennt es jetzt
nicht richtig, also, hm, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das irgendwie so hinkriege, dass es
nicht irgendeinen Pain gefocused hat, also das da unten ist Exa, das ist klassisches
LS, und das ist LSD, Bedgimmmusik, ja, das erste Easy, oh, Leute, ich muss, ihr könnt,
ihr könnt euch ja mal kurz überlegen, ich muss mal ganz kurz pinkeln,
because my
hat
Und auf was haben wir uns geeinigt, was ist das Beste?
Also ich bin da so ein bisschen, also ich muss sagen, die Ausgabe hier unten sieht schön kompakt aus
und auch ganz gut formatiert, aber ich mag sie nicht. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich extra
wieder runtergeschmissen habe. Ich habe das ja auch vor ein paar Jahren mal angefangen zu verwenden.
Der Grund, warum ich extra wieder runtergeschmissen habe, ist weil es nicht, weil es LS zu unähnlich
sieht. Und ich bin einfach LS Output gewöhnt und ich habe Remote auf Server auch immer LS.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, mir gefällt das normale LS am besten. Das da oben ist cool,
die Farbwahl ist vielleicht nicht so glücklich für mein Terminal und die Icons finde ich ehrlich
gesagt auch ein bisschen overkill. Ich meine, dass es in Ordner ist, weiß ich anhand der Farbe,
da brauche ich kein Icon davor und ob jetzt meine.files seine Icon davor haben oder nicht,
also wir können voten. Okay, bin mal gespannt. Ich glaube, die haben das alle nicht mitgekriegt.
Leute, die Voten, wisst ihr überhaupt, was was ist? Vielleicht hätten wir lieber 1,
2, 3 machen sollen. Original Karat. Hast du das Video geguckt? Vermute ich jetzt mal nach der
Message. 3 ist EXA, 2 ist LS und 1 ist LSD. Okay, die meisten Leute mögen LSD. Das hört sich
jetzt auch ein bisschen verkehrt an. Wenn ich sage, die meisten Leute mögen LSD. Aber es
bezieht sich natürlich auf das Commando-Zeilen-Tool. Okay, Leute, ich mir gefällt das normale LS fast
am besten. Also EXA schmeißen wir schon mal wieder weg. Zumal das ja auch kein Drop-in-Replacement ist.
Also das normale gefällt mir tatsächlich am besten. So, die Icons brauche ich halt nicht.
Okay, was kann man da jetzt zum Beispiel einstellen? Minus, minus, help. Schon mal extrem
viel Zeug kann man da einstellen. One Line. Doch bei List immer so, oder? Kein Unterschied.
One Line. All haben wir. Almost all. Logs. Hier kann man angeben, was, Default-Config finde ich
schon ganz, ganz brauchbar. Hä? Classify, was soll das machen? Minus F,
wo ist überhaupt der Unterschied? Ah, ob es ausführbar ist? Nee, hä? Okay,
was auch immer mir das Sternchen sagen soll. Hyperlink to Filenames. Ach, dass man das
anklicken kann oder sowas. Okay, Minus H ist schon mal sehr sinnvoll, aber das habe ich ja
schon angegeben. Ach guck mal, das kann direkt Recursive. Okay, das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Icon, Icon-Theme. Okay. Icon-Theme. Fancy. Uni-Code. Mein Freund kann das nicht.
Dann bleiben wir wohl bei Fancy, wobei ich eher für Icons, Icons off, never. Ja,
das sieht doch schon gleich viel besser aus. Das sieht doch schon gleich viel besser aus.
Was macht Hyperlink noch mal? Ach, okay, ich muss sagen, das ist, der öffnet es jetzt in meinem
Default, Default-Viewer dafür. Das ist gar nicht mal so unpraktisch, wenn du was öffnen willst in
irgendeinem GUI oder so und willst nicht, willst nicht XDG open oder Zeug da. Wobei, ganz ehrlich,
standardmäßig mir lieber ist es nicht anklickbar. Du bist auf jeden Fall aus Elfri- ja, korrekt,
benutze Seven-Zip, ja. Weiß ich nicht, ich klick das immer rechts an und gehe über das Menü.
Du kannst, du kannst rechts anklicken und über das Menü sagen, öffnen mit Seven-Zip.
Leider, ohne Render aus Elf nur noch sehr umständlich.
Wie kann man die Farbe ausstellen von den, von den, von hier, den Zeiten? Oder ist das nur,
weil ich gesagt habe, ich will nach Timesorten? Ups. Hä? Ach nee, jetzt habe ich mir dieses
komische Ding, dass, dass mein Home und die Buttons wieder in, in Sellas Hardware funktionieren.
Es hat ein Config-File. Also, okay, mein, warum nicht, warum nicht? Wenn man ein bisschen mehr
drin machen kann. Config. Config-File-Content. Classic. Hier, Theme. Das kann man noch mit Help
auch. Theme. Nee, das geht nur Icon Theme. Okay, man muss, man muss wirklich eine Config anlegen.
Alter, ich brauch's ja wirklich für jeden Scheiß mittlerweile eine Config. Wo muss denn die Config hin?
Ich, ich glaub's nicht, ich konfigurier mal ein LS. Source, Source. Theme. Was haben wir denn für
Dinger dabei? Colors. Black, Blue, Dark, Blue. Nee. Hat das, hat das irgendwelche Default-Themes
dabei, die man sich angucken kann? Oder gibt's da, gibt's da nur eins? Ach so, okay, die bringen
nur eins mit. Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber. Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber, mann. Ja,
klar, mann. Wie, wie bunt willst du dein Terminal haben? Also, mir würd's ja reichen, wenn man die
Farbe ausstellen kann bei, bei, also, Icons muss auf jeden Fall weg. Also, Icons. Oh, das, das
nervt, warte mal. Home und End Key not working. Fixed Settings. Da musste man, glaube ich,
irgendwie gucken. Okay, was für Key Escapes gibt das denn? F und H. Okay, danach kann man nicht,
danach kann man. Fixed Cish in MechOS. Ja, genau so was hier meine ich, genau so was brauch ich.
Also, irgendwelchen Gründen, ich weiß nicht warum. Bash hat überhaupt keine Probleme mit
den Buttons. Aber ZSH mag nicht ohne diese Config. Jetzt kann ich die Buttons verwenden. Alle anderen
Fenster und so, kein Problem. ZSH denkt sich, No Pass, gibt's nicht. Icon, was war's? Never.
So sieht das eigentlich ganz gut aus. Jetzt muss nur irgendwie die, jetzt muss nur irgendwie die
Color weg. Ah, okay, hier macht das, hier macht das unformatierten Output. Ja, okay, das kann sein,
dass, ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich ist das so, wie du es sagst, Andreas, aber sei doof,
dass das ZSH nicht interessiert, oder? Oder warum wird's nicht, wird's nicht mitgeliefert?
Die Color ist ganz gut. Ich weiß nicht, ich find das ziemlich, ziemlich bloated. Und ich hab
auch keinen Bock für mein LS, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Ich hab keinen Bock für mein LS.
Config Datei anzulegen, man. Und mir gefällt auch die Farbgebung hier vorne nicht. Also ich,
ich glaube, ich bleibe beim ganz traditionellen LS. Color. Ich glaube, ich bleib beim ganz
traditionellen LS und gut ist. Oder? Weiß nicht. Ich mein, wir könnten noch, wir könnten noch so
eine LS-Color. Dann sieht's, Installationen. LS-Color. Dann sieht das, sieht das ein bisschen
stylisher aus noch. Das ist aber noch nicht geladen. Wie lade ich das denn jetzt? Ja. Pacman
minus QL LS-Color Rit. Das muss ich, muss ich das sourcen? What the fuck? Vier Colors. Und Source,
LS-Colors. LHS. Das heißt aber nicht so. Das heißt einfach nur so. Der meint dir Colors
wahrscheinlich. Geh ich mal von aus. Okay, dann, dann machen wir das jetzt mal. Source.
Das hier oben zu den Suggestions. Ach, das hab ich noch gar nicht hinzugefügt. Das wollte ich
nur machen, Forehand. Okay, Source. So, und jetzt haben wir jetzt, haben wir jetzt nice Deer Colors. Hey, oah.
Das wird ja immer bunter, man. Seriously. Leute, ich glaube, ich werf das einfach wieder runter
und verwende stinknormales LS und fertig. Das braucht doch keiner. Ich weiß eh nicht,
was die unterschiedlichen Sachen bedeuten sollen. Warum ist ein Ordner nicht einfach blau,
so wie ich es gewöhnt bin? Es sind, dass letztendlich irgendwo sind es doch Sachen,
die die Welt nicht braucht. Ja, Source. Wir sourcen lieber Pacman minus QL Autosuggestions.
Exer hab ich auch probiert. Ja, hab ich sogar noch da. Hab ich nicht, hab ich schon wieder
uninstall eben. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen dem und dem? Sauce Autosuggestions. Toll. Source. Und
jetzt sollte ich theoretisch. Ah, ich sehe schon. Guck da mal. Aha, guck mal. Jetzt kann ich das
Auto Auto kompletten lassen, wenn es das ist, was ich haben will. Mal gucken, ob ich mich da dran
gewöhne. Gestern hatte irgendjemand oder vorgestern, weiß ich nicht, vorgestern muss das gewesen sein,
hatte jemand im Stream erzählt, wie geil das ist und er das immer verwendet. Ich bin ja eher der
Hist, ich bin ja eher der Historie Searcher. Also anstatt Historie zu searchen, könnte ich jetzt
auch quasi sagen. Tap, Tap, Tap. Wie Autokomplete man das eigentlich? Also außer, außer mit Ende
Taste. Gar nicht, gell? Suggestions. Tap. Was muss man dann drücken? Complete. Vielleicht auch
irgendwo drinnen? Usage. Hier. As you tell me, you will see. This color can. Autosuggestion
Highlight Style. Och nö, die Standard Farbe finde ich eigentlich ganz angenehm. If you press. Ah,
Moment, ich muss die File Taste. Ach, ich muss die File Taste drücken. Okay, ich kann File Taste
drücken oder End. Nee, da will ich nichts dran konfigurieren, das ist okay so. Kann man so lassen.
Das finde ich okay. Leute, mal gucken. Es schadet ja nichts, mal was Neues auszuprobieren. An sich
fühlt sich mal ganz gut an, die Sachen so auto zu completen. Die Sache ist nur die, ist das
5 hat und lernt, was man öfters verwendet oder schlägt es einem immer nur das letzte vor. Wie
macht es denn? Wie macht es denn? Macht es denn Fisch? Bei Fisch das, was man zuletzt in diesem
Directory verwendet hat. Okay, probieren wir mal aus. Downloads. Ach, ich wollte euch übrigens
noch was richtig Nices zeigen, was ich gebaut habe. Guckt mal. Passt mal auf. Hier sind Bilder im
Verzeichnis und ihr wisst ja, dass man mit Image Cat kann man sich jetzt auch Bilder im Terminal
anzeigen lassen. So wie die coolen Leute. Und ich habe den Alias gebaut. Guckt mal,
der zeigt das Verzeichnis an, wo man drinne ist. Alle Bilder. Und es ist noch advanceder. Also er
gibt da unten das, den Name vom Bild aus. Also listet alle Verzeichnisse. Und jetzt haltet euch
mal fest, wenn ich ein Verzeichnis auflisten lasse, wie zum Beispiel User, Share, Icons und
dann hier das Diffault Gnome Farbschema, werdet ihr gleich Folgendes feststellen. Also erstens
listet er total viele Icons auf. Aber guckt mal, SVGs kann der auch rendern. Und ihr werdet
feststellen, SVGs kann Westhörmlich. Das heißt, wie kann das sein, dass mein Image Cat Vektor
Grafiken rendern kann, wobei es das auch nur fake mäßig kann und das Image Cat was eingebaut ist
nicht. Pass mal auf, Sixhead Time. Ich gucke erst mal, ob das ein Image ist. Wenn es ein Image ist,
was mit SVG endet, dann nehme ich FFmpeg, skaliere das hoch auf 640x480, wandle das um in ein PNG und
dann pipe ich es an Westhörm und ansonsten lese ich mit Westhörm direkt das Image ein. Das heißt,
die SVGs, die ihr da gerade gesehen habt, wurden eigentlich on the fly in PNGs konvertiert,
sodass es das wieder anzeigen kann. Aber guckt, jetzt kann ich Bilder auflisten im Terminal,
inklusive SVGs. Das kann man sicherlich noch deutlich cooler machen und verfeinern,
weil das ja nicht SVG nimmt, sondern zum Beispiel, ich habe jetzt schon eine Verbesserungsidee. Man
nimmt nicht die Endung, sondern man nimmt Pfeil und guckt, ob das ein SVG Scalable Image ist zum
Beispiel, weil dann ist die Chance nicht so groß, dass man irgendeinen anderen Mist konvertiert,
den man gar nicht konvertieren will. Aber so geht es erstmal. Und jetzt kann ich alle Images
auflisten lassen. Nicht, dass es wirklich großartig Sinn machen würde, sich so ein riesen
Verzeichnis rekursiv im Terminal, da irgendwie, guckt euch mal die Rahmenauslastung an, lull,
da irgendwie im Terminal anzuzeigen, ist relativ unsinnig, gebe ich zu, aber es ist nice,
dass es funktioniert. Guckt mal, der RAM-Verbrauch. Der RAM-Verbrauch geht richtig ab. Fast schon 6
Gigabyte verbraucht für sinnlose Bilder im Terminal. Ach ja, und warum braucht es so viel RAM? Naja,
weil ich jederzeit zurückscrollen kann. Ich glaube, bald haben wir alles. Du musst das
parallelisieren. Du meinst, dass da irgendwie so ein Crit da draus macht?
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen komplizierter. Da musst du checken,
wie breit dein Terminal-Fenster ist und wie viel nebeneinander passt.
Obwohl ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob das funktioniert, das im Crit zu rendern.
Kannst du schnell zeigen, wie man Starship-Config machen kann? Ja, kann ich machen. Guck mal,
jetzt habe ich hier irgendwie 80 Milliarden Zeilen. Images. Mal gucken, wenn ich clear mache,
ob man dann den RAM aufräumt. Erstmal hängt das ganze Fenster. Blazingly fast written in rust.
Ach so, ich hätte vorher mit free gucken müssen, weil RAM-Anzeige ist ja gar nichts. Das hier ist
das Entscheidende, hätte ich vorher gucken müssen. Ja, also Starship ist ganz einfach.
Du installierst Starship. Falls du eine Anstellung hast hier über das Package. Starship. Hast du
wahrscheinlich schon gemacht. Dann gehst du in eine Shell-Config und trägst dort folgendes ein.
Je nachdem, ob du Bash oder Setters Haar verwendest oder Fisch. Und dann führst du das eine Kommando aus,
was da drinne steht und das war es dann. Dann suchst du dir hier irgendwie was raus. Das habe
ich zum Beispiel gerade. Und dann kopierst du dir das hier und führst es aus und dann
updates direkt deinen Prompt. Easy. Fertig. Mehr musst du nicht machen. Guck, wenn ich jetzt
irgendwas anderes kopiere, dann ändert sich direkt der Prompt. Easy. Aber ich behalte den,
finde ich nice. Das ist alles. Mehr brauchst du nicht. Kein Omae-Z-Dingsbums. Nee, das ist bloated.
Das ist West-Term, genau. Das beste Terminal, weil ich seit Jahren gefunden habe. Ich habe
die ganze Zeit letzten Jahre über Gnome-Terminal verwendet. Aber das wird ja nicht mehr weiter
entwickeln und ich wollte mal was Neues ausprobieren. Das ist richtig geil. Ich kann es wirklich jedem
nur empfehlen, weil du kannst deine komplette Terminal-Config customisieren, wie du willst.
Kannst du gar nicht Terminal-Pelua-Skripten. Beste. Poggers. Massive Pog. Guck, kann jetzt ganz
viel Terminals aufmachen und dann durchscrollen. Dann kannst du wieder zumachen. Nicht, dass es
jetzt Sinn machen würde. Zeigt das Starship-Theme auch an, in welcher.NET-Version das Projekt ist.
Also, das hier macht es. Ob das andere das kann, probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Also, das hier macht
das. So, jetzt machen wir das andere. Preset. Pestle Powerline. Nee, tatsächlich, das kann das
nicht. Das ist ein besseres Starship-Theme. Wo hast du das her? Wo hast du das her? Oder ist das
dein eigenes, dein selbstgebautes? Ach, du hast es selbstgebaut. Komm, wir gucken uns das mal
zusammen an. Ich muss mal nur gucken, dass da jetzt kein Chebat drin steht oder so, bevor ich
das ausführe. Man weiß ja nie. Mal gucken, probiere ich mal aus. Moment, wo muss ich das jetzt
reinschreiben? Hier. Konfig. Ach, Moment. Nee, nee. Vielleicht kann er tippen. Konfig. Starship-Tommel. Bäm.
Weird-Champ. Du hast, du hast, du hast Icons drin, die ich nicht installiert habe. Wo denn? Ich sehe es
jetzt gar nicht. Ach, hier. Spack. Spack. Spack habe ich nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was Spack ist.
Ist das nicht ziemlich das Default? Das ist doch so ziemlich das Default, oder? Nur, dass du den
Prompt, das ist das Default-Bracket-Theme, nur, dass du den Prompt zur Uhrzeit gemacht hast.
Sehe ich das richtig oder hast du sonst so irgendwelche Spezialanpassungen? Ah, guckt mal,
im Heimatverzeichnis zeigt das nur noch ein Häuschen an. Okay, das ist, und Downloads habe
ich auch gesehen. Desktop. Downloads. Ah ja. Nee, das mag ich nicht, weil dann kann ich den
Fahrt nicht kopieren. Ist aber eine coole Sache, finde ich, finde ich eine gute Idee. Also, wir können
es ja mal kurz versuchen. Liko, hast du es jetzt hingekriegt? Wir können es ja mal ganz schnell,
oh fuck, es ist 22.10, Leute. Lull. Eine Sache will ich noch ausprobieren. Ich will mal hier
.net-Configuration für.net reinmachen..net. So. Example..net-Symbol. Ist das ein Fenster?
Ist ein Fenster. Na, auch geil. Okay. Da kannst du jetzt aber mal kurz helfen. Nee, das.net ist
ja, da kannst du aber mal kurz helfen. Und wie, du hast es nicht hingekriegt? Warum? Das sind
doch nur drei Schritte. Muss ich das noch woanders eintragen? Ach, hier muss ich,
hier muss ich es wahrscheinlich noch eintragen. Hier muss ich wahrscheinlich noch.net hinschreiben
an der Stelle, dass es funktioniert. Okay. Repos. Ich meine, jetzt können wir das ausprobieren.
Repos. Ach so. Okay, das ist doch ganz praktisch. Und jetzt? Steht da nichts von.net.
Ich bin auch nicht im richtigen Ordner. Ah. Reset. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Du musst das in
diese Datei hier palpen. Nimm das doch einfach von der Homepage. Auf der Homepage steht doch
drauf, wie es geht. Du musst das hier kopieren. Das musst du eins zu eins so kopieren. Dann legt
es dir eine Config-Datei an unter.config, die Starship-Tommel heißt und dann aktiviert
sich es automatisch, wenn du es geladen hast. Das ist ziemlich broken an der Stelle, oder?
Leute, mir fällt gerade ein. Wir müssen dieses Theme noch etwas tweaken. Vielleicht nicht jetzt,
weil jetzt ist gerade ein bisschen wenig Zeit. Wie mache ich das Theme denn jetzt zweizeilig? Ich
mag viel lieber zweizeilige Themes, weil die dortfalls kommen auf GitHub. Weil guck mal,
es ist ja hier kaum Platz, wenn man sich hier viele Infos anzeigen lässt. Ich will das
zweizeilig haben. Hast den gekriegt, Pog? Den Branch kannst du auch kaum lesen. Stimmt, stimmt,
sieht ziemlich, sieht ziemlich. Ja, muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen die... Ich glaube,
das ist quasi zum Tweaken gedacht irgendwie. Wie macht man das zweizeilig? Presets, GitHub,
Starship. Wo sind denn die Themes? Ich weiß nicht, wo die Vorthemes sind. Dann machen wir
mal Presets und dann faken wir das einfach mal, legen wir das mal hier daneben. Preset von Symbols,
ja wunderbar. Das ist ja zweizeilig, oder machen wir? Das weiß ich, dass es zweizeilig ist.
Das ist pure prompt. Pure reset. Wie macht man das zweizeilig? Format. Alter was, das sieht ja
komplett anders aus. Okay, das muss ich mir morgen in Ruhe angucken. Das kriege ich jetzt
nicht mal gebacken. Das muss ich mal... Also ich... Line Break einfach, oder? Line Break. Einfach
Line Break an der Stelle rein. Also quasi, ja, wonach? Quasi nach dem, nach dem Herzchen quasi,
oder? Machen wir mal hier Dollar, Line Break. Wenn man es da so richtig schreibt. Hey, okay,
das sieht zwar hässlich aus, aber von der Idee her ist es doch easy. Das kann man auch ein
bisschen tweaken, aber das ist dann gar nicht so wild. Ja, die Farbe muss man noch ein bisschen
anpassen. Das Dotnet mit dem Hintergrund sieht kacke aus. Muss man sich noch was überlegen?
Wir müssen einfach mal GitHub suchen, was da... Aber das reicht für heute. Ich meine, es ist,
guck mal, es ist fast, es ist fast komplett nutzbar schon. Fast komplett nutzbar. Überhaupt kein
Ding. Wir müssen es noch ein bisschen umformatieren und der Rest ist eigentlich soweit, soweit fertig.
Also ich kann enttippen. Ups. Ah, entfernen geht auch nicht. Die Entfernentaste ist auch
gebrocken. Warum? Entfernen, weil das Ding in der ZSH fehlen würde. Ach, hier definiert man
den Background. Scala. Okay, Scala sollte einen Background haben. Hier, guck mal, hier Style,
bg. Okay, also geh mal Dotnet. Style. Ups. Style, bg. Leute, ich habe es gebrakt. Ich
habe es komplett gebrakt. Aber warum? Ah, ich habe zweimal Style. Was ist das für ein dummes
File Format? Was ist denn ein Tommel? Was ist ein Tommel in den Kommentaren? So? Ah ja. Boah nee, das kann man aber nicht erkennen. Das kann man nicht richtig erkennen. Da muss ich die Farbe noch ein bisschen anpassen. Aber es ist fast, es ist fast gut. Fast gut.
Weil die Farbe kann ja wirklich keiner so lesen. Also der Text da drauf. Ja, okay. Machen wir morgen weiter. Nee, nee, nee. Morgen machen wir nicht weiter. Morgen bauen wir an der Emulator-Kiste. Die Schrift in schwarz, ja. Würde ich auch sagen, weil man, ich muss mal ganz kurz noch gucken, wie man das einträgt. Schon von den Problemen der Samsung 90. Nee.
Samsung, weil ich habe ja so eine. Report rapid health degrade. Degradation.
Vielleicht ist da noch ein Anzeigefehler, oder?
Allround PC. Muss man mal schauen. Wie macht man hier den FG? FG schreibt man da also hin.
Also kann ich jetzt hier einfach hinschreiben? Wie würde ich jetzt dann dann dann den Leerzeichen? Okay, also Leerzeichen FG. Leute, ich kann es mir immer nicht merken. Ist es FFFF oder oder 0000 schwarz?
Okay, das ist der Background 00. Ah, nee, das ist durch. Ja, jetzt erkennt man es doch schon mal deutlich besser, weil jetzt.
Ja, ich muss jetzt ins Bett. Ja, ich will noch. Ich will mir noch den die Schriftfarbe raus kopieren.
Und zwar Vorgraund Alter RGB 2. Nee, Dings wie 2 Hex 2 Hex. RGB 2 Hex. Jetzt meine. Was 204 204 204.
So was. Excellent CCC. Perfekt, hätte ich schon mal gleich gewusst. CCC. Das heißt, ich muss FG CCC. Nein, so CCC machen. Was ist jetzt schon wieder das Problem? Ach so, doch, da muss doch noch Raute davor.
Das ist der Standard Vorgraund hier. Der funktioniert nicht so gut. Der funktioniert nicht so gut. Also vielleicht. Vielleicht muss man vielleicht muss man das alles ein bisschen bisschen dimmen.
Jetzt aber gut. Es war morgen weiter. Alles klar, Leute. Wir sehen uns morgen. Bis denn. Emulation Kiste basteln. Bis denn. Wir sehen uns zu.